Welcome to now you see it,
it affect his moment in a scary movie,
requires extremely precise editing and
camera direction to actually be scared.
I found a cool case study to outline
this idea in a movie currently out in
theaters called lights out the movies
based off of a short film with the same
name,
general concept and director.
What's interesting is that the movie and
the short film have a moment that's
basically the same,
but I think one is much scarier than the
other,
but what do you think?
Let's look at those scary moments and
see which one has done better.
Let's start with the movie
now.
The short film,
so which one's scarier?
My guess is you picked the short film,
but why?
Let's take a look at how the short film
perfectly uses many horror techniques
while the movie,
despite being so similar,
doesn't.
I think the most important difference is
the length of the clip.
The movie clip is actually from the
trailer because the movie still in
theaters,
the trailer cut makes the movie clip
about four seconds shorter.
In those four seconds to short film has
an extra flicker.
The lights with each added second is a
lot more suspense added to the scary
moment,
so when the pattern suddenly changes and
the ghost moves,
it's that much more startling.
Let's say you want to scare the audience
with a clown attack.
How do you do it?
Do you let the clowns sit motionless for
30 long seconds while we have no choice
but to uncomfortably stare at it
and then all of a sudden it's gone?
Or do you show the clown for a few
seconds at a time and throw in a couple
of random jump scares with no buildup or
continuity?
It's making the choice between one
really big scare or a bunch of little
okay scares,
which moment builds up the payoff
better.
Another difference in the two moments is
that the short film has a very powerful
shot right here.
It's from the creature's point of view
as it looks towards the woman like a
Predator stocking its prey.
This shot makes the woman look small and
powerless.
This is a shop we're all familiar with
in horror movies and that suspense by
showing a character being watched by the
monster.
The problem with the movie clip is it
just switches from her reaction to a
shot of the monster and it's not as
menacing as the point of view shot.
Finally,
where are they in the movie?
A warehouse.
It's never fully addressed in the movie
and it makes them limit less scary
because we're unfamiliar with the
location.
A big component of many horror films is
that these monsters or serial killers or
supernatural beings invade places where
we thought we were safe.
That's what makes it scary.
The call is coming from inside though
lesion is a real life fear,
and when we're in our pajamas heading to
bed,
that's when we're at our most
vulnerable.
The short film really capitalizes on
this idea and it's genuinely scary in
the movie.
We see an unfamiliar monster in a place
where already unfamiliar with so it's
not as scary.
Those are the three main differences I
think,
but you could go even deeper.
For one thing,
in the short film,
The lady is always bright in the shot,
so it seems more menacing when we can
see her clearly while also seeing the
ghost in the movie.
When the ghost is visible,
the lady can't really be seen,
so she seems more removed from the
monster and the threat.
I also think the ambient hum in the
background makes this short film
scarier.
Also,
the fact that in the short film,
The lady has to walk through the hallway
where the ghost already is.
That seems scarier than having the lady
already had the light switch,
but what do you think?
Are there any other aspects that make
the short film scarier?
Am I overthinking something?
Leave your comments below.
Getting a laugh requires a funny
performance or a well timed cut.
Getting people to cry,
maybe take strong characters and a
gorgeous film score.
Getting an amazing shot requires
compelling cinematography,
but to get a scare,
you need everything at once.
The music,
the timing,
the script,
the actors,
everything has to work together or else
it's not scary.
So before you go to sleep tonight,
ask yourself what scares me the most.
Thanks for what?
Sure.
Slightly
just a bit of a break from the break,
the monotony of all that.